si vous étiez à paris ce week-end vous
avez peut-être remarqué les drapeaux de
l'europe et des nations unies au
trocadéro 13 cents personnes
représentant 20 pays étaient réunis au
palais chaillot pas pour parler
politique
mais pour penser en silence les plus
grands noms du bridge e mondiale était
au rendez vous du palais de chaillot
pour la septième coupe d'or cino del
duca
depuis une quinzaine d'années ce sont
les italiens qui domine ce jeu de
l'esprit bien que battu l'an dernier par
les américains la france se situe pour
sa part au troisième ou quatrième rang
mais elle peut se flatter d'avoir 3
millions de pratiquants parmi lesquelles
un citoyen d'honneur
le comédien omar sharif sa passion pour
le bridge a littéralement transformé à
normaliser ma vie et ma vie personnelle
dans un des camps en étant éliminé une
vedette de cinéma normalement on a une
fille acer
on gravite dans des milieux
théâtre ou de cinéma ou de la société
l'aigle au bridge m'a permis d'avoir
beaucoup d'amis d'être considéré comme
une personne normale car les aux jo deux
joueurs de bridge s'en fiche qu'on soit
une vedette de cinéma d'ingénieurs ou un
médecin
ce qui les intéresse c'est le bridge qui
me regarde pas en tant qu'acteur mais
personne ne m'embête personnes me
demandent des autographes quand je fais
un mauvais coup au morgen comme tout le
monde
les gens gueulent mon partenaire dans
des frères mourir je fais très peu team
gp à 6 par an watine tous les deux ans
un peu près d'angers huit ou neuf mois
par an pour joueurs pour tous ces
joueurs dont les performances seront
programmés sur ordinateur afin de
déterminer les gagnants
l'essentiel est la concentration et ce
n'est pas facile dans une salle qui
connaît la même fréquentation au mètre
carré que la plage de la baule au mois
de la brittany ferries avait 18 ans
joueur de compétition en 1939 4000 après
le retour des prisonniers car les au
flag et les stalags ont servi de terrain
d'expérience pour bridge et dans un oeuf
la guinée n'est ni le premier tournoi
français de 400 joueurs et à la
libération quelques années plus tard
nous étions cinq mille nous sommes 23
mille voire de compétition aujourd'hui
et dans ce tournoi dans cette grande
pudeur claudel du cac c'est la plus
grande manifestation française du bric
avec mise à 200 joueurs près de 600
terre tous les milieux sont présentés
l'association des ptt
l'association de brice de la ratp ici du
romantic
certains comptes italiens et que
certains grands d'espagne